[Music]
on this monday night ontario's troubling
trajectory covet 19 cases and deaths
heading
off the charts the numbers we are seeing
are scary why the province is rejecting
a curfew
out of the house and back inside schools
i was a little bit worried about what's
going to happen
the tricky balance between avoiding
covid and maintaining kids mental health
potential breakthrough the weed being
used to create another vaccine and
the canadians behind it plus inching
closer to the u.s president's
second impeachment this man is a danger
every day he remains in office
and the canadians tracking down the
capital attackers
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is january 11
2021 and that means it is one year since
the first known death
from a mysterious illness was reported
in china
since then of course covet 19 has
altered all our lives and the pandemic
is now worse than ever
in multiple countries case numbers are
rising variants have been discovered
that are much more contagious
transmitting the virus more rapidly than
ever
and thousands more people are dying
every day here's the grim
big picture more than 1.9 million people
worldwide have died of covid 19.
in canada more than 17 000 people have
died
quebec has recorded the most deaths per
capita 102 deaths per 100 000 people
the next hardest hit province is
manitoba with 54 deaths
per 100 000 people in ontario more than
5 000 people have died of the virus and
the number of people ending up in the
hospital now is
rising sharply more than 1500 ontarians
are hospitalized with covid19 right now
387 of them are in intensive care 268 on
ventilators
the numbers we are seeing are scary
covet 19 morbidity
and mortality are at the highest levels
we have seen since the start of the
pandemic
tomorrow ontario is set to release new
projections about what's coming premier
doug ford has said the picture is so
dire he says you'll fall off your chair
when you hear it
yet he is waiting to impose tighter
public health restrictions
abigail beeman has our top story in
what's driving the surge in cases
and what must be done to slow it down
criticized for threatening tougher
restrictions and dangling
upcoming modeling for days we worked all
weekend
ontario's premier is still tight-lipped
we'll be going to a cabinet with
recommendations we'll make an
announcement tomorrow sources who have
seen the modeling tell global news by
the end of the month cases could double
to more than 6
000 a day and that's a conservative
estimate there are 387 people in ontario
icus
by early february that could reach
between 750
and 1000 aggravating a real capacity
problem
and sources say the number of daily
deaths could more than
double reaching a hundred a day by the
end of february
even watching percent positivity all of
a sudden after the holidays we saw
sudden increases in a whole bunch of
health units
which suggested that it's not just an
isolated thing but there was much
widespread gathering that must have
happened over the holidays
ontario says it will announce new
restrictions tuesday some say much like
announcing the province-wide lockdown
days before enacting it that's too late
the time to act
is now a curfew like quebec's now off
the table
it was not recommended by the health
table we are slowly descending
into the madness of trying to lock up
everybody infectious disease specialist
dr neal rao believes the focus should be
on hospitals dealing with the strain
he supports moving patients to other
hospitals and delaying elective
surgeries
it's bad to delay care but if it's a
short-term fix
that's what we do we can look at hiring
retired nurses and doctors
if we're short of people we can look at
deploying people
who are family doctors who are working
from home remotely
to help out in urgent care settings or
intent hospitals
and with mobility data showing ontarians
flooding retail pre-lockdown and not
enough people working from home
underlying the stark numbers is another
question
i don't think we know yet how much of
this is due
to the uk variant the genome sequencing
needed to detect the uk variant takes
much longer than a typical
covid test up to two weeks public health
ontario has developed its
own pcr test which can detect both the
uk and south african variants
in an effort to speed up the process and
try to answer questions about ontario's
surging cases abigail beeman global news
ottawa not all people
choose to follow the advice about
avoiding non-essential travel and some
get
fired for it another ontario hospital
ceo has lost his job
dr paul woods has been fired by the
london health sciences center he went to
the united states five
times since last march to visit family
his most recent trip was over the winter
holidays when one of the hospitals he
oversaw was struggling to contain a
covet-19 outbreak
last week the ceo of niagara health and
saint joseph's health system lost his
job
after spending the christmas holiday in
the dominican republic
quebec's premier francois lago says he
is impressed with how quebecers followed
the rules on the first
weekend of a province-wide curfew there
police handed out 750 tickets to curfew
breakers over the weekend
the curfew order is in effect between 8
p.m and 5 a.m for the next month
fines for non-compliance range from 1
000
to 6 000 and one woman apparently tried
to skirt the curfew which allows people
to walk their dogs by putting
her husband on a leash police decided
husbands don't qualify as pets and
find the couple well schools in quebec
alberta and northern ontario reopened
in-person learning today early on in the
pandemic health organizations
called on policymakers to make schools
and education a priority
but at the height of the second wave
finding the right balance for students
and parents
has never been more difficult heather
eurix west has that story
for parents able to once again drop off
their kids at school
monday morning was a mix of anxiety and
relief the online learning i found was
really tough on me especially working
we're a little bit worried about what's
going to happen you know we're hoping
that the kovit 19
case has remained low in-person learning
has resumed in many
parts of canada even as covet 19 levels
soar schools generally reflect what's
happening in the community
so when community transmission is high
transmission within schools is high as
well
dr tecine lada is part of a group of
doctors calling for alberta to delay
in-person learning until covet 19 case
numbers fall
her biggest concern is the uk variant
and what we're really worried about is
that we don't actually know the
prevalence of the uk variant in alberta
right now
if it is prevalent it will just spread
like rapid fire
and it will be taken home to parents and
elderly family members
who live within the home and are at high
risk from covid
alberta began to see its new infection
numbers drop about two weeks after grade
seven to twelve students switched to
online learning in november
numbers fell further after other
businesses like gyms and hair salons
closed on december 13th
and grade k to six schools shut down on
december 18th for christmas break
in an ideal world dr steven friedman
agrees it would be better to wait for
case numbers to fall
but he says the decision to reopen
schools cannot be based on the impact of
covet 19
alone as a pediatric emergency medicine
physician i've
never seen the mental health strain on
our children
as bad as it currently is it's rare for
children to become
seriously ill from covet 19. the concern
with schools is that asymptomatic kids
will bring the virus home probably the
most important
message is although we are restarting
school or in-person school for children
everything else needs to remain the same
because with case numbers high the
relatively
safe return to school we saw in the fall
is not guaranteed now
heather urex west global news calgary
now to washington d.c
dual actions are underway to strip
president trump of power
house democrats introduced an article of
impeachment against him today for
incitement of insurrection saying he
gravely endangered the security of the
united states it accuses him of inciting
the mob that attacked the capitol last
week
why try to impeach him when his days in
office are numbered
because it could prevent him from ever
running for president again
and house speaker nancy pelosi ratcheted
up the pressure today
vowing to press ahead with impeachment
unless vice president pence
seeks to remove trump under the 25th
amendment by wednesday
jackson proskow reports for what purpose
the push to remove donald trump
resolution calling on vice president
michael r
pence led to a formal call for the vice
president to invoke the 25th amendment
to declare president donald j trump
incapable of executing the duties of his
office
while democrats introduced a single
article of impeachment for
incitement of insurrection which will go
to a vote wednesday if trump doesn't
resign
or isn't removed before then this man is
a danger every day he remains in office
nine days before his term expires trump
is set to become the first president in
history to be impeached
twice my feeling is if we impeach him
this week that it should be immediately
transmitted to
the senate and we should try the case as
soon as possible
even if the senate doesn't conduct the
trial portion of impeachment before
trump leaves office it may do so under
president joe biden
an attempt to bar trump from ever
holding public office again
there's growing fear that trump
supporters are emboldened by last week's
storming of the capital
[Applause]
new details show they came perilously
close to lawmakers during the siege
some of those arrested were carrying
restraints and weapons
washington dc's attorney general
suggested trump could actually face
charges
for inciting the violent mob those were
outrageous
comments that those individuals
including the president of the united
states
made clearly the crowd was hyped up
juiced up focused on the capital fearing
a repeat attack in washington
15 000 members of the national guard
have been activated
the washington monument has been sealed
off ahead of the inauguration
our goals right now are to encourage
americans to participate virtually
the fbi is now warning of the
possibility of armed protests in
washington and all 50 state capitals
over the course of the next two weeks
and there are several rapid developments
unfolding this evening the acting
secretary of homeland security has
abruptly resigned his post
political donations from major
corporations are being suspended to
republicans who objected to the
electoral college results
uh we also hear now that republicans are
considering censure as a softer form of
punishment
against president donald trump but that
impeachment vote is set to go ahead on
wednesday at this point donna
and that's the same day that enhanced
security measures will begin here in
washington
one week before the inauguration a lot
going on in the next nine days jackson
proskow in washington thanks
president trump's social media options
are dwindling twitter and facebook have
banned him and now
parlor an alternative platform that's a
favorite of conservatives
is suing amazon for removing it amazon
web services shut down the site last
night saying we cannot provide services
to a customer that is
unable to effectively identify and
remove content that encourages or
incites violence against others
parlor is suing amazon claiming the move
was politically motivated
parlor which builds itself as a free
speech social network is now virtually
homeless
apple and google had already removed it
from their app stores
some other organizations are distancing
themselves from trump and his businesses
the pga says it will not hold its 2022
gulf championship at the trump national
golf course in bedminster new jersey
the hotel chain marriott is halting
donations to republican senators
who voted against certifying joe biden's
election win
and financial institutions like
citigroup j.p morgan chase and morgan
stanley have also frozen political
contributions
a sign of corporate america's growing
uneasiness after the violent attacks
inspired by president trump some
companies promised to re-examine their
role in funding
american politicians former republican
governor
arnold schwarzenegger released a
powerful video statement condemning
trump
schwarzenegger was born in austria just
after the end of the second world war
and says
he knows where trump's lies can lead
president trump is a failed leader he
will go down in history as the worst
president
ever the good thing is that he soon will
be
as irrelevant as an old tweet but what
are we to make of those elected
officials
who have enabled his lies and his
treachery
i would remind them of what teddy
roosevelt said
patriotism means to stand by the country
it does not mean to stand by the
president
those who stormed the capital are being
tracked down thanks to their bragging
and bravado plus the relative of the
tobacco plan
that could be a new weapon against
covid19
the rollout of vaccines in canada is
slowly ramping up and there's criticism
it's not happening fast enough
only two vaccines are approved for use
in canada though there are agreements to
buy five
other vaccine candidates still in the
approval pipeline
one of them is canadian medicago is a
quebec based company using new
technology
as carolyn jarvis explains it could be a
breakthrough for vaccine science
under the hum of industrial fans row
upon row of a hardy weed grows
it's called nicotiana benthamiana a
cousin of the tobacco plant
which is key to quebec-based company
medicago's
covert 19 vaccine candidate i'm
not just optimistic i'm confident that
it will work the plant is used to create
the
19 spike protein and wraps it in a
virus-like particle
the host the human who gets that sees
that as
oh that looks like a virus and
because it looks like a virus the immune
system responds very well to it
in phase one of its clinical study
people who received two doses of
medical's vaccine showed a significant
immune response
people who just who are recovering from
infection
have this many antibodies and people who
get our vaccine
have that many antibodies that's pretty
good
we're very happy with that no
plant-based vaccine has ever reached the
commercial level
medicago is set to enter phase three of
its trials later this month
and if successful could provide doses to
canadians by the second half of this
year
if it's approved for use the bulk of
medica's doses won't
initially come from canada that's
because despite
years of lobbying the federal government
for funding for pandemic preparedness
and to build a manufacturing plant in
canada the money medicago needed
didn't come in time the reality is it
took covet to get a decision made for
whatever reason and i think this is what
we have been talking to them about from
for
months and years this is about securing
potential vaccines for canadians
it wasn't until this past october that
the federal government announced 173
million dollars
to support medical's vaccine and to
accelerate the building of its
production plant in quebec city
but plants take years to build and this
one won't be ready until the end of
2023.
it didn't need to be this way frankly in
the meantime canada's vaccine if
approved will mostly come
from the u.s from a facility it funded
back in 2010
when it saw a need for pandemic
preparedness
it's good that the canadian government
is now supporting a canadian company
since
the u.s government supported the
canadian company first carolyn jarvis
global news
toronto
still ahead digging out after record
snowfall brings parts of spain to a
standstill
[Music]
it is all hands on deck in madrid people
are digging out from a snowfall
that smashed a 50-year record in spain
members of spain's military spent the
day clearing a highway
thousands of people were trapped in
their cars for 12 hours the blizzard
dumped more than half a meter of snow in
some areas many health care workers had
to walk to work
now a sharp drop in temperatures is
turning the snow to ice
pope francis is giving women bigger
roles within the catholic church but it
is not a precursor to making them
priests
the pope changed the church law to
officially allow women to read scripture
and serve on the altar as eucharist
ministers during mass
that's already common practice in many
developing countries
pope francis is under pressure to allow
women to be deacons as well he created
a second commission of experts to study
the matter after a first one
failed to reach a consensus but the
pontiff reaffirmed
that women cannot become priests
up next how canadian social media sluice
are tracking down
america's capitol riders
one of the darkest episodes in american
history is coming into sharper focus
the pro-trump mob that stormed the u.s
capitol organized it on social media
platforms and some people made no
attempt to hide their identities posting
selfies and
bragging about what they did now they're
being tracked down and arrested
as mike drollay reports their bravado is
proving to be
their downfall
nothing stood between the mob and the
capitol building
history they believed was being made and
they wanted everyone on their social
media feeds to bask in the glow
of their success i can't believe this is
reality
but something happened on their way to
support a former reality tv star
the very medium president donald trump
used to rise to fame
came back to bite them this isn't a
political revolution it's a social media
revolution it's a technological
revolution
it's a revolution for right-minded
citizens who decided that they're going
to use technology for good
and they're going to use it to go after
those who committed what is basically a
very serious crime
by the time the fbi had put out its
wanted poster social media
investigators had already begun
identifying the most notorious rioters
starting with the guy wearing horns and
fur but others were less known
so toronto-based citizen lab guru john
scott railton
rallied his followers and was able to
identify former air force pilot
lieutenant colonel larry brock through
the very specific
patches he wore on his body armor
another man dressed in paramilitary
fatigues proved more difficult to find
until the first piece of the puzzle fell
into place
the cap eric munchell wore was from a
small tennessee-based coffee company
the information was sent to the fbi and
both were arrested over the weekend
it took a few days but the rioters
eventually realized what was happening
and began scrubbing their feeds if
giancarlo fiorella of the investigative
journalism site bellingcat didn't
anticipate that happening
this picture of nancy pelosi's unlocked
computer might never have been found
so if you see the tweet there he says i
am inside nancy pelosi's office
yeah with the thousands of
revolutionaries who have turned the
building so that tweet is
is gone bill and cat's findings are all
open source so it doesn't need to
forward what it uncovers to the
authorities
but you can bet the fbi is keeping tabs
because it's making their jobs
a little easier why did you want to go
in
we're storming the capital it's a
revolution mike drolite global news
toronto
and that is global national for this
monday it's hard to find funny things
these days so we're taking the laughs
where we can get them
in this case it's a dad in ireland who
tried to record a happy birthday message
for his son
hello hello
vincent mcdonald he couldn't get much
past the word hello
what should have taken 20 seconds took
over seven minutes but it is seven
minutes of pure joy
hello david how are you
the video became a viral hit it's had
more than a million views
and vincent brightened up everyone's day
not just his sons
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
and take care of yourselves